naval ravikant you probably know him as
the founder of angellist
a prolific twitter philosopher or one of
the few silicon valley insiders to ever
appear on the joe rogan experience
but his life story is actually full of
ups and downs that inform who he is
today
and can be really instructive to
prospective entrepreneurs
i'm john coogan and this is the saga of
nival ravikant
naval was born in new delhi india in
1974
but moved to new york city when he was
just nine years old
his parents separated when he was still
young so he was raised by his mother in
queens while she worked long hours and
attended night school
consequently neval had long stretches of
time where he was left to his own
devices
which he made very good use of here's
naval describing his upbringing
on the joe rogan experience i was raised
by my
i was raised by a single mom in new york
and she used the local library as a
daycare center because it was a very
tough neighborhood and so she would
basically say when you get back from
school go straight to the library and
don't come out
until i pick you up late at night so i
used to basically live in the library
and i read everything i read every
magazine i read every
pictograph i read every book or every
map i just ran out of stuff to read i
just read everything
his voracious appetite for knowledge
served him well and he was able to test
into a public magnet high school
named stuvescent by performing well on
the admissions test
since his mother didn't earn enough
money to pay for a private school
a tuition-free public school like
student was really the only option for
naval to gain a strong education
he took his studies seriously and was
able to attend dartmouth after
graduation
with the help of a financial aid package
naval didn't go directly into technology
or entrepreneurship after graduation
though
instead he went to work for the boston
consulting group where he got exposed to
the inner workings of large corporations
and learned some business fundamentals
management consulting is a common
jumping off point into other careers
since it gives you a good overview of a
variety of different businesses
and instills strong analytical skills so
neval
left consulting to go work at a
high-speed cable internet provider
named at home this was in the late 90s
when internet stocks were booming
and at home was no exception at home
merged with excite
a popular web portal at the time and the
combined company was worth seven billion
dollars
but nevall had higher aspirations than
growing rich in a comfortable position
at a late stage tech company
he wanted to start something of his own
so he walked away from four million
dollars worth of unvested at-home stock
options
and joined august capital as an
entrepreneur in residence to start
planning his venture
this turned out to be a great move since
the high flying company did not make it
through the dot-com crash in 2001
at the peak of the bubble the company
was worth 35 billion dollars
but by october of 2001 the company had
filed for chapter 11 bankruptcy
protection
and naval shares would have been
worthless if he had stuck around
naval quickly assembled a team of
co-founders and raised a massive seed
round of 8 million dollars for this new
company
half of the funding came from august
capital and the other half came from
benchmark capital
and this funding round was believed to
be one of the highest seed valuations
for a company
ever starting a technology company was
much more capital intensive in the 90s
you had to buy actual server hardware
since aws
didn't exist yet so neval's close ties
to venture capital
really helped him get started here but
it wouldn't all be smooth sailing
his new company was called e-pinions and
the idea was simple
create a place on the internet where
anyone could review anything
the site had sections for reviews of
cars computers
and even physical places like ski
resorts this was all before yelp and
there weren't many competitors in the
space
neval served as ceo and grew the company
incredibly quickly
hiring 31 people in the first 12 weeks
less than one year after launching the
site epinions was able to close a 25
million dollar series a
but things started to get difficult for
the company after the dot-com bubble
popped later that year
the site reached nearly 6 million users
in 2003
but valuations of tech companies had
fallen so much
that there wasn't much hope for an ipo
noval and three of his co-founders left
the company to move on to new projects
leaving narav talia and the vcs from
benchmark in august
in charge of the company when growth
stagnates it's not uncommon to see a
change in leadership at a startup
and with 45 million dollars invested in
e-pinions the venture capitalists were
probably just focused on getting the
company to acquisition
so they didn't lose their entire
investment while naval had moved back
into the venture capital world
he received some news about e-pinions
the company would be merged with a
comparison pricing site named deal time
but the common stock that naval owned
would be worth nothing
naval and his co-founders approved the
merger which is completely reasonable
if the company you founded is struggling
and a merger will keep the product alive
and allow the company to avoid layoffs
it's immoral to block that merger on
principle
you gain nothing and it just winds up
hurting employees customers and
investors
but after the merger was completed
things got much more complicated
e-pinions and deal time relaunched at
shopping.com
and in 2004 the company went public at a
valuation of 750 million
everyone made a killing in the ipo but
naval and his co-founders had nothing to
show for it
so they sued in the lawsuit naval and
his fellow plaintiffs
alleged that their co-founder nirav
talia and the vc firms
had misrepresented the value of
e-pinions at the time of the merger
in order to get them to give up their
shares lawsuits between founders and
venture capitalists are extremely rare
this is because vc firms have vastly
greater resources to
fight off lawsuits and no founder wants
to be known
as someone who sues their investors it's
usually better just to move on
bury the hatchet and start something new
with a different group of investors
but naval had good reason to believe he
was being misled
especially after documents showed that
e-pinions was on the verge of signing a
deal with google
that would more than 10x the company's
profit right after the merger
they wound up settling the lawsuit out
of court so we don't know exactly what
happened
but i think a few things are likely here
the first
is that naval definitely got paid it's
unclear how big the settlement was
but naval was able to raise a 20 million
early stage venture capital fund
shortly after the settlement so it's
likely he got at least a few million
when you're raising a vc fund it's
typically expected that 10 to 20
of the fund will come from your own
capital there are of course exceptions
but it's unlikely that he would have
been able to close this fund without a
few million in personal capital
it's also extremely likely that everyone
signed a mutual non-disclosure agreement
and non-disparagement agreement as part
of the settlement
meaning that naval could never talk
publicly about exactly what had
happened even though naval couldn't
discuss the opinion settlement
stories about a young founder
successfully suing his vcs
echoed around silicon valley and helped
him earn a name
as someone who had been through the
wringer once again
naval was able to capitalize on the
opportunity in front of him incredibly
well
he started writing a blog called venture
hacks which offered detailed advice on
negotiating term sheets
and other information usually reserved
for experienced
silicon valley insiders he also started
angel list
with the goal of democratizing the
startup investment process
naval has spent the last decade laser
focused on the early stage fundraising
process
and he's grown angel lists significantly
adding products around recruiting
cryptocurrency and equity crowdfunding
and he's also continued to carve out
innovative content marketing strategies
and created a very unique voice on
twitter in one of his most successful
threads
titled how to get rich without getting
lucky he
maps out his entire philosophy on wealth
accumulation
in a series of extremely succinct tweets
the thesis of the thread
is that there are no get rich quick
schemes but by focusing on developing
specific knowledge
that can't be easily taught in schools
and then applying leverage through
technology
capital or media anyone can accumulate
wealth
with enough time and effort this type of
pithy tweet
is sometimes criticized as fortune
cookie twitter and when done
poorly tweets like these can come off as
cocky but naval has a great explanation
about why he tries to boil things down
so much
and this is where twitter is great for
me is i try to understand something and
then i try to write it down in such a
way
that i could remember it just the basic
hook that'll point towards the
deeper understanding and i'm forced to
explain it to people and that's how i
know i understand some things
the density of information exists on a
wide spectrum
on one end you might have a textbook or
academic paper
with copious sources and data supporting
each argument
and on the other end there are these
fortune cookie tweets but that doesn't
necessarily mean that one is better than
the other
you have to consider the goal naval is
taking his own advice here
and using leverage as effectively as
possible
he could probably spend months writing a
book that would sell a few thousand
copies
or he could write these uniquely terse
tweets that reach millions of people
and it makes sense for him to cast as
wide a net as possible
because he invests at the earliest stage
and wants lots of entrepreneurs to use
angellist
and naval isn't just focused on
entrepreneurs anymore he's also
innovating on the way angel investors
raise capital for their
funds in 2020 angellist announced the
rolling fund
to allow more people to get into angel
investing the rolling fund is unique in
a few ways
generally fund managers need to raise
their entire fund's capital
in a short period of time but rolling
funds are
always open meaning they can accept new
investments at any time
this also lets the fund capitalize on
big successes
to raise more money for the fund so if a
portfolio company breaks out
and raises a huge round of funding a
rolling fund could immediately add a
bunch of new limited partners
and then be able to make bigger
investments immediately
the second big innovation with rolling
funds involves marketing
typically managers cannot market their
funds publicly
which is why you'll never see an
advertisement to invest in a vc firm
but rolling funds fall under a special
sec
exemption called rule 506 c
marketing securities directly to the
public is always controversial
because there is a real risk that stock
promoters will take advantage of
unsophisticated investors
we've seen leonardo dicaprio play the
role of one of these penny stock
scammers in the wolf of wall street
and ben affleck played a similar role in
boiler room
both great films but the fact that
certain startup investments have
performed phenomenally well
over the past few decades and average
investors have not had access to that
asset class whatsoever
makes a really good case for allowing
unaccredited investors
to gain exposure to startup equity
markets
like i discussed in my earlier video on
chamath palihapatea and spax
financial innovation will always come
with risks and plenty of criticism
naval is undoubtedly aware of the fact
that scammers could try to abuse rolling
funds
and that could hurt the entire industry
i personally hope that these rolling
funds
get stress tested and wind up having a
positive impact on the startup ecosystem
as an entrepreneur i'm generally in
favor of anything that will bring more
funding dollars
into the early stage sector of the
economy since that will support
innovation and allow more people to
start companies but it's always
important to weigh the societal costs
and risks of abuse against these
financial innovations so we don't end up
with another 2007 financial crisis on
our hands
so it's 2021 now angel list is bigger
than ever and naval looks poised to
dramatically reshape startup financing
but what about all that epinions drama
between neval and benchmark capital
fortunately it looks like they were able
to reconcile somewhat
and let it be water under the bridge in
2016
bill gurley one of the vcs that neval
sued sat down with kara swisher on a
podcast and discussed the e pinion's
lawsuit
here's what gurley had to say about
noval ceo was naval robbie
yeah that's right and interesting story
about him
we ended up splitting uh from him and
there ended up being a lawsuit
and this was i don't know 16 17 years
ago and
and i had always thought of naval as one
of the the smartest people i'd ever met
but
when someone sues you you tend to get on
the other side of things and
just this past winter i was in um
at a ski event that chris sacca put
together and he was invited we sat down
and we talked for the first time
yeah it was awesome it was just like it
reminded me of why we worked together
in the first place but i regret that we
spent 16 years not chatting
he's obviously gone on to do uh do some
spectacular
it's great to see that they were able to
let bygones be bygones and move on from
the
opinions drama and in an interesting
twist both naval
and gurley wound up making a fortune
when they invested early in uber
naval was in the seed round and gurley
led the a round
so the big takeaway for me here is that
success in business
requires the right amount of aggression
if someone is really taking advantage of
you
a lawsuit might be your best bet but
there isn't much to be gained from
trashing them publicly
ultimately other opportunities will come
around and if you work hard enough you
will eventually find success
naval made the best out of a tough
situation and was seen as an
outcast in silicon valley for quite some
time but his willingness to fight for
founders
paid off as the valley shifted to a more
founder-friendly model
and his experience in the trenches
became something that founders loved
but what do you think of naval let me
know in the comments if you liked the
video and how it shaped your view of
silicon valley
and if you like this type of video
please consider subscribing to the
channel
i have a bunch more in the pipeline if
you want to get in touch with me
you can message me on twitter and as
always thanks for watching